You may or may not be aware that Donald Trump
is suffering yet another major loss to his
administration.
This time it's the director of national intelligence.
Dan Coats, coats is resigning and as usual
there's this question of whether is it really
a resignation or is it a firing?
Because Trump's relationship with the intelligence
community has been pretty disastrous since
day one and Dan Coats is one of those people
who when he testifies before Congress and
is asked basic questions like, did Russia
interfere in our elections?
He goes with what the evidence has told the
intelligence community.
The answer is yes.
That's not a position that Donald Trump likes.
And it appears as though removing Dan coats
is yet another way to pave the way to not
stop foreign interference in 2022 ignore the
attacks on our democratic systems, which is
exactly what Donald Trump and Mitch McConnell
have made it super clear they want to be doing
for 2020 Mitch McConnell getting in the way
of every uh, bill or proposal met to stop
foreign interference in our election.
So coats is going out.
Trump has nominated republican congressman
John Ratcliffe who truly knows nothing about
being the director of national intelligence
and has no business being the DNI.
This is, I mean, language starts to lose its
meaning.
It's a stunning choice and to call something
stunning in the Trump administration.
The Trump era is a sort of limited meanings
since we are stunned.
Day after day, a Democratic Senator Ron Wyden,
is calling him the least qualified individual
ever to be nominated to be DNI and says that
Ratcliffe could straight up put people people's
lives at risk.
Check out a couple of tweets where Ron Wyden
says, congressman Ratcliff is the most partisan
and least qualified individual ever nominated
to serve as DNI.
His only qualification seem to be promoting
Trump's conspiracy theories about the investigation
into Russian interference and calling for
prosecution of Trump's political enemies continuing.
He has endorsed government surveillance and
shown little concern for Americans' rights
except for those of Trump and his close associates
confirming this individual would amount to
an endorsement of this administration's drive
to politicize our intelligence agencies.
Putting in place a director of national intelligence
who has repeated baseless conspiracy theories
about the Russia probe that have been widely
debunked by the intelligence community is
disgusting and embarrassing.
He senselessly and embarrassingly berated
former special prosecutor Robert Muller last
week during the congressional testimony, if
you wanted to destroy the American intelligence
apparatus from the inside out, if you had
the goal of weakening our intelligence community,
this is exactly who you would select.
A Republican conspiracy theorist who has spread
fake news and false intelligence.
It is really difficult to be less qualified
than Donald Trump's education secretary Betsy
devos, and yet here we are.
I think that this guy actually surpasses Betsy
devoss as not qualified for his position.
And when you look at the reaction of this
from foreign intelligence agencies, the intelligence
agencies of foreign nations are drooling about
this because it will laughably weaken the
United States.
It will make us more vulnerable.
And I wish I could say that our Senate will
do its job and prevent this clown from being
confirmed to the roll.
I don't know that they will.
I don't know that they will remember that
Republicans control the Senate and thus they
control the committees that ultimately decide
about these nominations.
And I don't know that they are going to put
a stop to this.
It's disgusting.
It's embarrassing.
It is a handout to our adversaries, but it
seems to be a feature of Donald Trump's selection,
not a bug, that this is a guy that would effectively
unwind the intelligence community from the
inside out.
And the world is laughing and your life and
my life and the lives
of so many people in this country are potentially
at risk as a result of this choice.
Trump will probably get his guy in.
We'll take a quick break
and
be
back
after this